thank you
[Music]
foreign
up
here
foreign
up
[Music]
foreign
here we go
we live shall we live
we live shouting we back we back we back
you're you're welcome everyone
you're welcome everyone
we back Happy New Year
happy New Year bro
getting it going
aloha
[Laughter]
how fun
[Music]
it's gonna be a good year
you think so
oh yeah it's gonna be it'll be like the
last three years worth [__] it's got to
be the best one yet you know what I mean
like that's true
between 2020 and uh the remix of 2020
and the new remix of 2021.
2023 has got to be like
no more remixes we just here that's
right
I like that
I like that optimism of it can't be any
worse
that's one man's philosophy you know
what it's been so bad for three years
that it's like how much worse could it
get
it's only up from here
so hello oh we okay we here now Alan
Michael Harbor says Aloha Adit yeah long
time no see Andrew Lapointe
hello
yeah yeah
would love to see my feedback now it's
been five months nice
welcome back
good to see you
yeah good to see all of y'all
welcome back welcome back welcome back
that's right happy New Year what am I
doing are we I'm representing PCU all
day long all day long
all day long
we missed y'all so much it's me right
here Joe all day long let's go
the frogs I'm literally I've been
wearing this like well I've been wearing
it all week since we won but everywhere
I go I'm represent letting everybody
know yo I am with it you went to TCU I
was like hell yeah I went to that small
school that could that's right
how how small is the school
uh about it's now maybe 12 000 but when
I went it was like 7 000 students wow
wow yeah that's so dope I'm so excited
for them man I'm rooting for them yeah
man everybody should root for them even
even it since even though it is against
Georgia I'm still I want I want the
underdog to win
yeah
but that Georgia game
was dude it was what so here's the thing
I had a gig uh
uh that night and I'm DJing and I'm
supposed to bring in the New Years
[Laughter]
but I was supposed to bring in the New
Year's while this game is still
happening because the gig is I'm only
playing music during the commercials of
this game
[Laughter]
DJ gigs are worse than comedy gigs gosh
it was it was still worth it I still had
fun I still had a good time like I mean
and afterwards we were able to party and
like really like make it like a real DJ
Gig uh but for the like right when
I had I set my clock right at 11 59 I
was like all right now I got a timer so
I can see it and I'm like all right most
people just do like 15 countdown from
like 2015. I get to the countdown from
15 seconds and I was like all right I I
turned off everything I was like we're
gonna bring in the new years as the
kicker is going on oh my God it
literally kicks it
he misses it I'm like happy New Year
all the Jewish people just erupt it was
nuts
it turned out perfect I saw they they
did like a they showed a countdown timer
on the clock and like it timed up with
it hitting zero yes yes it's crazy
crazy yeah
the DJ at the stadium had to do the same
thing because they had to bring in the
New Years right they had to bring in the
New Years even in the stadium
but they ran out there so quickly I
thought somebody called a timeout I was
like oh maybe somebody called a timeout
but nah it was that was the kick he
missed it
[Music]
I did not want Georgia to win but hey I
I definitely want Georgia to win but
like I don't I'm not like go dogs I
wanted Georgia to win for George's sake
just because it is Georgia but um I want
TCU to win the finals
yeah and I'm going to the game are you
really
yeah I do where is it
uh la
oh you're pulling up Shawty let's go
sometimes there's moments in life when
you're like okay can you actually make
this happen and like how often is your
alma mater gonna go to the National
Championship yeah A Moment Like This
some people wait a lifetime oh Tracy J
said I've never been here on a Tuesday
well welcome this is not normally what
it is
um we're usually doing joke feedback but
you got you got two beta men talking
Sports so yeah
in here good to see you moody John mom
Dragon Chris James
The Man From Mars Harold
I just thought about this Joe I'll come
and go
betamingo no
ball that's what we call it football
Jerry Kroll yo we deep yo we haven't
been on in like two or three weeks and
we are 22 people so
shout out to the hot breadth of verse
for not giving up on us
let me give them an Applause
because I was about ready I didn't know
what they wanted us to do
yeah I don't
I'm glad they still love us that's good
I was a little worried because we did
rightfully so take a few weeks off but
I think the value that we are providing
is
so good
yeah I mean yeah it yeah it's too good
to be true that's what my wife says
I'm gonna take this love that we're
getting and use it to pay Comcast yes
the karma
y'all y'all accept uh Karma
Georgia Power you all accept Karma
y'all take payments and passion I got
Karma on Deck
which Speaking of karma y'all can go
watch my new video about fluffy
that'll be good karma
I haven't seen that one yet
oh
I think you just put it up
[Laughter]
yeah oh yeah it's a fun one it's doing
the best yet each one's getting better
and better so I'm excited for that to
make money
um
we just just started a whole other job
that's what it's all about fun
I did I did I got offered
uh a gig on New Year's
that was gonna be like downtown it was
gonna be at the underground
uh-huh and uh and it just I don't want
to be down there at that time
not for that
no the booker asked me he's like does
that sound like something you'd be
interested in and I was just like
it really isn't
it it was going to be three shows
one of them at midnight I was just like
and all that traffic I was like
I no it doesn't I appreciate you asking
though
but to all the young Comics you take
everything you get
but
I don't want to lead by bad example but
I feel like I've been doing it long
enough to where I didn't need
to be miserable for fifty dollars you
know what I mean but early on go for it
kids
yeah dude that's uh
that's a smart move there's a thing we
all got standards you know I mean like
and the standards just they pile on as
we go deeper and deeper into this you'll
be like there's some places that I won't
do comedy yeah I mean not a lot there's
just some places we're like
nah that's a bad idea
but for the longest I had the worst
standards so we should preface this
I performed everywhere for like 10 years
I did sidewalks I did strip clubs
I did buses
I did fetish conventions
I did it all
so I don't want to come off dainty
but
[Music]
but I I think yeah I think that's a lot
of young Comics will be like oh is this
show worth it or not I mean for the
first I mean at least five years
everywhere and anywhere at all times
like every show I don't care if it is a
bar at 1am in front of like and it's a
Monday you know and it's in front of six
other Comics all that adds up I think
you gotta do all those
um and then you start to you know stop
doing some of those after you but I
think the first at least five years you
got to do anything anywhere
I'll show you on that one
but at the end of the day it's also
personal preference so
it's what you what you want to do
yeah
yeah that's all that matters man
uh yeah things you gotta do make it
happen
oh
oh yo
um
oh Adidas said let the fun begin yeah so
post your jokes
um poster joke she would like some
feedback on
Michael Harper said haven't been here in
a while working on being an author very
cool
noise
508 bunnies done a bus department stores
roof of a car in a parking lot
hilarious
I don't think I've ever done a roof of a
car that's different that's that's a new
one for me yeah I've never never done
that one
508 funny I wonder what that area I
guess that's the area code I wonder what
um where that is where is that 508 funny
rebased
oh and you know something interesting
as people
uh post their jokes
is that the Thunder did you hear that
yeah so there is a tornado watch
yeah
so like yeah it's like I think it's all
Southeast so
for whatever reason the power literally
may just shut off so I just want people
to know that
um
so I don't know what we're gonna do
um with that but hopefully it doesn't as
we're on here for the next little bit
oh and Tracy J said I love you Joel
thank you
likewise I don't want to say that I
don't want to reciprocate and then my
wife's leaning in the in the doorway and
she's like oh who's Tracy J huh is she
on the patreon or is she just
yeah
they're all on the patreon yeah
at this point yeah
nice oh something I wanted
to bring up to you because we've talked
about Netflix a lot
um
napargatsi
is releasing an Amazon special
this is
Mr Netflix he built his career on
Netflix he did that like half hour and
then he did the specials on there
and now at the end of January he's
releasing an Amazon special and he said
that it was because
uh he could get ownership of it
yeah and with Netflix you can't
yeah Netflix owns your material
I mean that's the power here's the thing
everyone does that but
Amazon also owns your material so does
he own it like just outright
that's what it sounded like yeah because
he talked about it on his podcast and he
said that because here's the thing
that's what everyone does right anyone
who has a new network they make those
deals like oh if you come to us
you will get you know you ownership
right because that's what the other
networks don't offer I'm surprised that
like
peacock Paramount HP already does comedy
specials aren't doing comedy specials
as well EMA like all different places
just because the comedy pieces
I mean maybe it's just my algorithm but
there's a lot of comedy specials out
yeah a lot of Netflix specials maybe not
on other networks but you know HBO Max
still has a couple of specials
I did watch a couple I watched Chris red
special it was pretty solid I enjoyed
that one
um on HBO Max uh but yeah I think that's
legit that's awesome
yeah it's just it's just interesting to
see that someone like Nate who built his
career on Netflix is now like I'm just
gonna go I'm gonna go with Amazon
because it's a better business decision
and this is something we've talked about
with like kind of Netflix is kind of
like have they peaked and are they on
the other side now if they offered us a
special we're like of course but I I
think that's a big deal that Nate
who was kind of like the Netflix comic
is now taking his business elsewhere I
think that could be a sign of the tides
I mean
is he like
what do you think other people would do
it or do you think there's enough
options out there
YouTube Schultz hear me like Schultz
basically took his net took his I don't
know if it was Netflix I'm assuming it
was Netflix the way he made it sound
let's just say he took his Netflix
specials back
and then release it himself
and now and then he got sponsors to
actually do the ads with inside the
actual special itself so he just
released the ads in the specials
um and he owns all of it in essence you
know
um whatever YouTube is paying you for
however many views you're getting right
so
I just think it's a matter of like the
universe has opened up more for a comedy
like we've said it's kind of becoming
this golden age of Comedy where people
are really consuming a whole lot more I
mean clips and you know it feels like
comedy is becoming such the thing that
is helping the algorithms win on the
platforms
mm-hmm yeah which is why I mean people
like Netflix invested so much in comedy
to begin with was because it's
it's well it's one it's original content
that they don't have to create the
chameleon does all of it but it's also
it costs way less to produce a comedy
special than it does
US 10 episode series anything it costs
less I mean literally let's rent out a
place let's put lights let's use the
camera we were gonna use oh and we can
literally record it in like four hours
maybe two two nights and then you do the
same four recordings or maybe just two
nights all in one night and you just get
Lights and Camera for the whole thing oh
absolutely
you know I think that's that's the key
is I think somebody in at uh South by
Southwest mention uh executive mention
that
their jobs are much easier now they just
look for people who are already blown up
they don't necessarily have to go find
them any longer yeah
yeah that's that's the game yeah
so we shall see but I just thought that
was interesting and I hadn't really
talked to another comedian about
going to Amazon instead of Netflix I
thought it was interesting yeah open up
the universe baby
all right maybe we can like maybe he can
open it up to where it make it makes it
easier for us to submit stuff to Amazon
yeah yeah I mean you can submit your
special to Amazon but for them to buy it
you know I think you you can't submit
and sell on there
there's like a process you can do but um
yeah for them to buy it just it was just
interesting yeah because what's the name
just released released his on Amazon
didn't he
um clean comedian Gaffigan did
yeah again yeah yeah
his last two on there didn't he I
believe so yeah he did one where he like
did special he did like a four-part
special in different countries and did
jokes basically about each of those
countries and that was like a four-part
special
I didn't see that one that's solid yeah
and it's all like specific to that area
so he kind of like just created
for like kind of mini specials in there
which is a cool idea yeah that's very
cool that's smart
so yeah it'll be it'll be interesting to
see I just uh
thought that was big he's Mr Netflix and
he went to Amazon I thought that was a
big thing so I shall see
um so yeah we're doing joke feedback
Alvaro asked if there's a theme or just
submitting jokes so just submit your
jokes
um
so we know that it is a joke rather than
a comment and everyone who is here is
also free to like add tags and other
things like that to your joke as well
after we review it so yeah it's a
community we're not the only ones sort
of with all the great ideas although
ours are pretty solid I'm just yeah you
know
you know like our idea to do this every
week for free you know like those kind
of good ideas
those
where are you are you listening Alexa
Alexa are you
Karma
get me an a special
John mondrager said the theme is funny
the theme is funny yes
hopefully we shall see we see a lot of
good jokes rolling in here so let's get
the timer
and um
I think the first joke I'm seeing here
is uh from Harold
I think Harold
Bart
yep
sorry
[Laughter]
let's start the new year off right it's
just damaging these names
all right
sorry we know we're straight this is our
first one back from the holidays I've
been
on a bender with sugar so I'm two days
sober though baby we're back we're back
and we're sticking to it this time
yum
um yeah we're good two days it's gonna
be great
yeah
uh
laughs
oh
all right
um
I just remember it had some chocolate
covered almonds that were already open
so I better finish them
it's you know the worst part about being
a grown-up is you have to like try
I think that's
I'm coming up on yeah I'm gonna be 35 in
like two weeks and it's like oh
I have to like try all the time all the
time
[Music]
all the time and nobody cares
nobody
everyone is be like pissed off we got
more important things to do for sure yep
yes
that's not a terrible premise
what was the worst part about being an
adult is you having to try yeah that's
very funny I don't hate that yeah
um all right so let's all right so we
said all that to say Harold here we go
uh invited friends
none made it this is a great start
already the structure is really on point
so far
um inviting friends none made it one
said they prefer to come next time oddly
enough that's also what my girlfriend
said this morning some people may call
her needy I call her imaginary
all right
um
I get it
I think we don't need so much of the
stuff that's there
um
I'm trying to think like how to I think
this is just a structure a badly
structured joke
it doesn't the premise isn't necessarily
clear here
but I get that much
I think it yeah it's it's a long way to
say
my girlfriend
or it's a long way to say I'm bad at sex
is essentially what the premise is it's
like my girlfriend doesn't she'll come
next time you know what I mean like
yeah so there's a lot going on around
just saying that thing so just looking
at this joke as is and like just how we
could get to that quicker and
structurally
couldn't it just be like
um
I don't know
visiting family I prefer I don't I mean
this the joke is so I think
I invited friends
um no one showed up and they said they
come the next time oddly enough that's
what my girlfriend said
some people call her needy I call her
imaginary just take that there's so much
fluff in between like
her saying it this morning that has
nothing to do with it uh the invited
friends none made it we have no idea
what you're talking about so just don't
like it's not needed just say I invited
friends to a party like pick a place
because you're inviting people just to a
random thing it's very odd uh yeah I
invited friends to a party no uh none of
them made it uh
oddly enough or they they said they'd
prefer to come next time that's what my
girlfriend said some people call her
needy I call her imaginary so I think
it's just taking up all the unnecessary
but having a clear premise about what
this joke is about
yeah first yeah yeah which is I think
that's the biggest issue is right now
the premise isn't very clear yes
cool yeah
but thank you for sharing there
absolutely
good start
um
oh it looks like a d it did one that got
flagged
he said I read a quote
stating I'm not taking your turn I was
just reading it off the screen because I
can't pull it up
I didn't want you think I was colonizing
your turn
um
I read I read a quote stating When The
World Turns its back on you you turn
your back on the world
since then I am not able to do doggy
style
When The World Turns us back on you you
turn your back on the world since then
I'm not able to do doggy style
so I think it could personalize
to where not I read a quote
or
but I mean like
but I get it yes I read a quote to my
girlfriend my girlfriend read a quote to
me
but yeah you can personalize it right up
top
and then now yeah and then
now doggy style is
now I'm the bottom or something I don't
know yeah
yeah I mean even just the sex reference
itself I don't get
because it's like
yeah like doggy style back to back I
guess that's what that's that's the part
it's like
it's so weird because I think this is a
this is a symptom of like
when you're making a joke and then you
take it to a sexual reference
it's hard if we don't understand what it
is that you're talking about
where it feels like the joke is just a
sexual reference that you wanted to say
you know what I mean like it's almost
like you just wanted to say doggy style
yeah you know I'm saying there's no
reference to what actually
the joke itself meant
yeah kind of like the previous joke
about like just wanting to say why like
imaginary
yeah yes or like wanting to yeah say
she'll come next time like it's kind of
like oh I have this funny line idea
yeah but like but why the premises have
to be clear
so that's a good place to start yeah ask
yourself what am I trying to say in this
joke that's basically what
uh the premise is what are you trying to
say what is the message of this joke and
then you can kind of build it around
that
yeah
um Ryan Schwartz said my joke I don't
see you posted one Ryan if you do post
it in the live chat and we'll get to it
buddy just be sure to put the word joke
in front of it as we have uh 508 funny
coming up next
all right my New Year's resolution is to
be more confident like the confidence
Wikipedia has when they ask you for
money like there's their information is
accurate
right
I get it
um
I think the problem with this is that
there's too many things
I like the confidence and I like and I
get that premise
I'm just wondering if there's a bigger
surprise other than Wikipedia asking you
for money
because I think if you're if you're
saying that Wikipedia asks you for
uh money like their information is
accurate
you're also assuming that people know
that the Wikipedia information isn't
accurate
right so like you're just making too
many assumptions that people should know
that they're asking you for money but
that their information is not accurate
and I think that's the problem with this
it's not clear
yeah so it could be my comedy New Year's
resolution is to be as confident as
Wikipedia
ask for money using unoriginal material
yeah or yeah ask for money with
unverified information or something like
that something like that and that does
require people to then know Wikipedia
may not have
valid information like you're making a
few assumptions there that the audience
may or may not know overall
but that kind of at least gets to the
the core of the joke a little better
mm-hmm
yeah all right we cooking now it's been
a minute but we back in it
watch and feel free to
um
uh post your jokes in the live chat of
course but then also feel free to share
feedback
on each other's jokes you know we're a
community of comics helping Comics so
anyone that has
ideas for each other feel free
um
it looks like up next we have Alan
Michael Harbor
his joke
I miss my old job because I used to have
the shortest commute
I lived in my car
I like this I think we are making an
assumption that you drive to your car
I mean you drive to work so that's the
only thing that feels missing here is
the assumption that you're driving which
obviously is your misdirect but I think
if you made that connection here the
joke will pop a little bit more
yeah because I'm reading it as he worked
in his car
yeah you're reading this that I'm
reading it as he used to Drought travel
to us travel to his job and that took a
long time
which is why he misses it because he
used to have the shortest commute I
lived in my car
right so it's like you just have to make
the reference that you did used to like
drive further or you know I'm saying you
have to make a driving reference it
could be working from home
yeah and he he's working from home is in
his car
that's the thing is like
because working from home and not
commuting is a thing now that we think
about
this may not hit because people may just
assume well you could have just worked
from home versus you working in the car
so there's just a lot of assumptions
here that that I think you got to be
clear about
where to go there Alan Michael Harvard
thanks for sharing fam
um
we have uh Mr Stephen or Rogers a hot
breath alum
yeah yeah
um uh he's been on the Pod a few times
and we were talking about specials
earlier he has a great special on
YouTube right now as well
just the dry bar just dropped as well I
believe oh did it erased I haven't seen
that one yet but I did like the special
uh I lost two wallets in 24 hours it's
hard to blame a thief when it's two
can't be like wow this guy's good
that's funny uh actually the only thing
I was thinking is
like can't be like wow this guy's too
good
um just to add that reference back to
the two wallets
um but I see it I lost two wallets in 24
hours it's hard to blame a thief
when it's two
yeah but this I feel like this joke is
assuming the same Thief
stole both
or is he saying
or it maybe the punch on is about him
being
bad
like if he's lost two wallets in 24
hours maybe he's the one
with the problem
um so that's a good point because I've
made all the assumptions but you didn't
I just assumed that there was just a
thief following him be like oh this
guy's just gonna get another wallet so
I'm gonna just steal that too
oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so maybe to your point it
should be clear that it's the same Thief
okay
yeah
cool beans cool beans yeah yeah is there
an echo
am I echoing no it went away am I
no
okay it went away
awesome
well thanks for sharing there Steve
yeah Stephen
wait hold on all right
I knew that was coming all right
uh next Juke oh we got a lot coming in
oh we could we had 33p
oh let's go go
[Applause]
dab
we out your cooking fam
um
all right
next joke
uh uh mudit
was this for mine
yeah
uh I don't hesitate to wish people happy
New Years since it's Universal until I
met a flat earther and politely said
happy holidays
um I like this because I get New Year's
means
a revolution around the earth uh-huh
but I'm not sure if anyone if people
would get that
that that's why you're telling the Flat
Earth or happy holidays
but I got it
is that you're smart you're smarter than
everyone else is that what you're trying
to say you're better than everyone
because you got it oh and the Heart the
homie Dario said really like that one
medit so they got it you call the smart
people are like yeah we got that one
tracks
just running circles around the rest of
us huh
all right
[Music]
um okay
he said thank you I might say Global
instead of universal
that could help yeah I don't hesitate to
wish people happy New Years since it's
global
or maybe it's um
happy New Year is a global
phrase unless you're a flat earther
I just don't I don't know happy holidays
doesn't really connect with flat earther
is there like a word play
um something that rhymes with new year
but is in relation to flat earther
um
I mean even like happy new day would be
funnier
just it's just another day if we're if
you're a flat earther
um
I just happy holidays doesn't really
correlate specifically with flat Earth
so if there's something Flat Earth
related I think it would make it punch a
little harder
I can see that
but
the time is up we must keep it rolling
with our timer because we do have a lot
of people posting jokes we rolling deep
in here Shawty go let's go baby but
please in the comments feel free to give
each other joke feedback and share ideas
um
we can only do so much in just a minute
but
um
we're happy y'all are here with us
next up is uh Chris James
all right you can tell corporations are
evil they'll put cocaine and soda pop
but they won't make caffeinated dental
floss they really cared
they put drugs in children's toothpaste
established a habit
I like it
um
it might be a little long
uh
but I get
I get the Beats of the joke
I think you don't even have to say like
you can tell corporations just
corporations are evil they put cocaine
and soda pop but they won't put
uh caffeine and dental floss
they really cared they'd start putting
drugs and children's toothpaste
establish the habit
and then I think like a
uh like a tag on
one caffeine a day keeps the floss away
or something like that oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I like that yeah like four out
of five
doctors recommend you start habit
until today keeps the doctor away
yeah yeah yeah a grandma day something
like that yeah that could be funny word
play
nice yeah I like the premise though
that's it's funny
um but I think you can definitely like
shorten it up that way you can get to
more funny later
yeah Cafe dental floss it's like a funny
phrase but I don't know how much it
serves the joke
um
but they'll make cocaine soda pop but
not caffeinated dental floss I don't
know that that kind of like
distracts from the flow of it I feel
like yeah
um
yeah I feel like if you're just gonna go
with drugs just put cocaine or like put
a hard drug in there
I mean yeah you said in soda pop but not
cocaine and dental floss
You Hear Me Like Cocaine it's lost like
just something that maybe keeps the beat
like Molly and flosser yeah yeah yeah
but yeah like you said if they care
they'd put drugs and children's
toothpaste like there's a lot of humor
and detail and specificity so telling a
specific drug
as well
yeah yeah
I like that very nice very nice
uh nine out of ten doctors are addicted
to Colgate Tony Baloney said Dr Tony
Montana
next joke
is
foreign
Chris James homie Dario
oh
antonyms
am I going to get canceled for saying
this word indones are when foreigners
have a different name for a country's
citizens
than what they call themselves example
German say Deutsch
most other countries refer to Americans
as diabetics
all right
I don't hate that
I I don't hate it either it's pretty
it's
very well structured I think the only
thing would be
um
just going like that explanation of
antonyms just to clear that up just say
Germans when Germans say Deutsch it's
called an endonym basically
people who call their countries citizens
different than themselves then hit the
punch line
most Americans most other countries call
Americans diabetics so just like that
whole explanation thing of the antonyms
could be a little shorter
but I like it I like that too yeah say
Deutsch diabetes diabetics yeah
yeah
yeah I mean even just yeah Germans say
Deutsch
other countries Americans uh
yeah almost like Americans are called
diabetics
yeah yeah as German yeah to tighten it
up it's like so for example Germans are
called Deutsch like Americans are called
diabetics or something like that
yeah yep
kaboom
ha
boom all right
we got to get him on the podcast we
should get him on the podcast for sure
we're gonna get him on the podcast
yeah getting him on the Pod for sure
we are I mean it for sure I do
I'm just gonna start making this show
the podcast I just don't
we're just gonna start bringing people
on here
be like all right it's podcast
it is though
um it works it works yeah yeah I mean we
haven't done that yet but yeah
dab on them
oh this is the Jordan year
all right uh
[Music]
where are we
uh Joe chihotic
you're gonna have to turn up your mic
gain to give me feedback
all right
I got it a nice word play there I see
you Joe
uh Oliveto
I've dated so much in Atlanta I get
Wi-Fi everywhere
okay
I don't I don't think I get it
basically he's been in so many places
that basically just gets Wi-Fi in a lot
of places oh so he already has like the
password to the Wi-Fi
yeah
I think that's the only key is like to
mention
something around
going around a lot because it's not
clear just you getting Wi-Fi
everywhere to your point right like
because dating so much you could just be
dating online but it doesn't mean you go
everywhere
uh
and that's the only thing that would be
clear like I've gone on so many dates
I've gone to so many restaurant dates in
Atlanta I get Wi-Fi everywhere that'd be
clear
yeah or I have more Wi-Fi passwords than
second dates yeah something like that
yep
yeah we need more we need more detail
here there's a lot to fill in here
yeah but it's I like the premise
mm-hmm that's pretty clear
oh he said thanks guys well you're
you're welcome
happy to help buddy
sure sure that's on dating aren't you so
glad
you don't have to date anymore dude dude
I uh
I I think I've written this joke down
that like if I was to pick up
like a new lady like my first thing
would be do you have a to-do list yeah I
mean like that's my that's what I know
how to do right now right yeah a
honeydew you already start a honeydew
list yeah
yeah that's all I'm good for you know
what I mean I don't have any new skills
non-transferable skills yeah no none not
at all your resume yeah I'm yeah I'm so
glad dude oh my gosh
um
yeah I couldn't date I couldn't date in
this new modern time
it's different it's different out here
in these streets
I'm glad we got out when we did
[Laughter]
um next it looks like
Elaine
let me see I believe so
I don't want to mispronounce your name
Elaine am I saying that right
sure oh Sinatra liked a to-do list
I think they maybe took that as like to
do maybe it could be like uh like a
h
um
um oh I was just thinking Wi-Fi signal
isn't there like a dating signal or like
something maybe Wi-Fi I don't know let's
move on
um
all right
Elaine
did you read did I read the last one I
read the last one this is yours
um Elaine myleen when a belt becomes an
accurate representation of its owner
it's mental state
only Holding On by aesthetic stitches
Bell becomes an accurate representation
of its owner's mental state
well I think making this
autobiographical will help
and turn making it about you so it's
like when your belt
becomes a representation of your mental
state it's only Holding On by aesthetic
stitches
yep yeah yeah and I think just aesthetic
stitches just feels like a mouthful
so I'm just wondering if there's a way
to make that clear yeah sometimes yeah
yeah because it's like my belt
represents like even if you're saying my
belt has become a representation of my
mental state Holding On by Stitches or
even just yeah maybe that yeah that's
what Alvaro said buy a thread yeah hold
on by thread yeah yeah yeah I think like
I think it's an example of like trying
to be more clever than clear
yeah
yeah which we all do we all want to be
great brilliant writers but for comedy
literally a lot of times it's like what
would a second grader understand
facts so um
yeah good edit there Alvaro and thanks
for sharing there Elaine
yeah nice
I'd want to hear more that's really
funny
it's a good premise yeah yeah agreed
gone by thread or just how you're
holding on probably just just Aesthetics
alone that that's like a really fun
that'll pique my interest like on stage
yeah nice and personal
yeah
um up next we have
uh Tracy J
CJ there we go
I just caught
I just caught my favorite wine on sale
for half the usual price and I just have
to figure out who started the rumor that
money can't buy you happiness they must
get their wine for free
oh that's fun yeah that's a fun one
um
timer
I wonder if there's a delay because I
feel like people are commenting way
later than
we're like saying something and then
it's like literally like a few minutes
later
there might be a delay I don't know
um
maybe it's like whoever said money can't
buy you happiness
clearly hasn't gotten their wine half
off
oh yeah they must get it for free
yeah
yeah I haven't gotten their favorite
wine half off yeah
yeah and even on the first line like
I think there's too many words just
I just I caught my favorite wine on sale
for half the price
like just quick edits you don't need the
usual you don't need to just
um right like I tend to be like trying
to make it so immediate I just thought
about or I just had a run-in with like
no I had a run-in
I thought this like just don't use those
I don't know what that word is what
liberal arts person do you know what
those kind of words are justifiers like
just and usual
yeah fillers filler words
or that
you mean failures
feelers fillers fellas fillers fellas
pillars fellas
nice
I like it though nice job there Tracy J
uh uh Tony Baloney
I think did you read the last one I love
I think I'm reading this one maybe
oh
why do they call it a doggy style
[Laughter]
all right Focus
all right really real cerebral stuff
coming in here
why do they call it doggy style that
feels like the worst Seinfeld premise
ever what's the deal with doggy style
um
read this in a Seinfeld voice
why do they call it doggy style don't
all the animals animals the doggy style
I mean how many animals do you see doing
a missionary style it should be called
animal style
for the podcast
that'll be 900 million dollars thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
um I get the premise of the joke but I
feel like that's one of those jokes
because you're asking so many rhetorical
questions just say what you're trying to
say
um rather than putting it in question
Style Just
there's no reason to call it doggy style
all animals do a doggy style
do you ever see animals doing it
missionary
or animals don't do it missionary they
should just be called animal cells
something like that but actually
somebody mentioned reverse cowgirl
um which is funny
yeah I
I
um
yeah I was thinking yeah I just I don't
understand why they call it doggy style
I've never seen
wait yeah instead of just asking just
saying I don't understand why they call
it doggy style
all animals do it doggy style I've never
seen one do it missionary it should be
called animal style
I mean it's not funny that when I said
it like that that way in the Seinfeld
voice it was way funnier
so uh yeah like missionary also isn't
enough of a
like you said like I don't think enough
of a surprise but I get the
I think yeah like a reverse cowgirl or a
wheelbarrow or just if you name other
styles then I think you'll get
wheel bear
you just rolled that one off you know
when you're doing the wheelbarrow
[Laughter]
you know when it's when it's a Thursday
afternoon
there's a pile of laundry and you're
like just real quick
just do the wheelbarrow
oh somebody said I've never seen two
cows going at it and they call it
missionary
oh yeah yeah more detail specificity
yeah
nice
cool beans
thank you Tony Baloney for inspiring
wheelbarrow
oh
[Music]
the man from Mars
um
my uncle works at a local hospital he
helps deliver babies but ever since
Epstein got caught he doesn't have many
customers to deliver to
oh
that joke is from Mars
um
I don't I mean I mean one it's an
Epstein joke I mean
just just in general the timing you know
what I mean like is it still relevant
is it still relevant and you can do
better
it's like yes this is so low brow like
bottom of the rung kind of like joke
like it feels too easy it's like a it's
like a Catholic uh like child abuse joke
it's yeah you're done yeah
but yeah your uncle a doctor that's
interesting if it's true and like
pulling from your own personal life
is always going to get you farther and
help you find your voice faster this is
yeah you're better than this
like because you start with your uncle
being a doctor which is funny
in the sense of like not funny but it's
interesting and then you go like very
conspiracy theorish people just aren't
even going to believe it it's like okay
it's like this is one of those cases
where you just wanted to put Epstein in
the joke
yeah and it's not there like you're
gonna get more of a groan then you're
gonna get a laugh
I'm gonna get one of those
[Music]
uh next Scott
spinos
finesse
Scott sponus
uh Sticks and Stones might break my
bones which is exactly why I'm terrified
of going camping
all right all right
[Music]
um
instead of terrified
maybe scared
it makes it punch a little harder you
know what I mean
yeah fixing stones may break my bones
pause making sure you put a pause there
which is why I'm scared of camping
Sticks and Stones I don't know if
there's something more than camping
like is there something more related
than camping to Sticks and Stones as
well
oh John said at least that's why my dad
said he wouldn't take me camping
yeah a few more specific
yeah I don't know I think the Beats of
this is what's throwing me off
which is like which is exactly what I'm
terrified of going camping I think what
I'm wondering is
like
yeah something about camping
I like that yes I get that camping is
the punchline
but
hmm
I think I'm looking for more
on this if that makes sense
because there's no like you're terrified
huh
yeah it doesn't connect enough to stick
some Stones I don't know I mean it's
but this also feels like a like it's
like an idea that anyone could kind of
have like it's not like a it doesn't
feel like something super personal to
Scott
yes that's what that's what that's what
stole me off it seems a little more
generic yeah
and
I'm all always my favorite jokes are
always the ones that are like the most
personal
where we're learning something about the
person it's something unique to their
point of view and their life experience
this just feels like it's a joke anyone
could say and it'll get like kind of the
same response you know
yeah
all right we'll keep it there but we
appreciate you sharing Scott and we
appreciate all of y'all for sharing
but this is joke feedback this is not
joke law so if you're like oh screw them
I'm gonna go do it go for it you know
what I mean like we're just here to give
feedback and ideas based on our
professional experience but by all means
still you do you boo yeah try this on
stage see what happens
yeah it'll be uh
um
coming up next we have uh Victoria in
our Facebook group and she said
um
that let us know when we're in New York
and she can put us on our show her show
at a Broadway Comedy Club
oh awesome
thank you for sure
sweet
um
we gotta go on a tour Joel
we do
yeah that's true yeah that would be fun
uh
that would be fun
yeah it would be fun it would be fun it
would be yeah it would be a lot of fun
we should do that
yeah we should definitely do that yeah
we should let's do it yeah
um let's do it my calendar
it's not here yet so I'll work it on
that calendar
yeah and um I think my budget's coming
in the mail soon too so we'll try to
figure out
well we'll figure out a middle ground
there on time and money
um
foreign
but for the hot breath of Earth you know
we do it for the culture too you know I
I I think it's time to do a hot breath
with Joel and Yoshi tour you think so
yeah dude
I'm with it yeah
cool
um
all right Victoria
is this do I read this one yes yes golly
we have a lot of
who's a lot of jokes man
they miss us they're like now all right
let's let's all right
all right let's get to it here all right
let's let's stick to the timers I was
like scrolling through the comments like
oh my gosh we have a lot of it's a good
thing and we appreciate it yes
absolutely
um
so whenever I get into an argument with
my husband I call customer service for
my phone just to talk to someone who can
give me the respect I need I talked to
Steve Sanjay from India
and he always seems so happy to help me
I have no issues with my phone but I
have had so many arguments with my
husband I'm flying Sanjay into New York
now
that's a funny Arc that's a funny
transformation twist there
yeah
um
I mean I like this premise I just think
it can definitely just be shortened like
I I get in arguments with my husband so
I call customer service on my phone
I speak with Steve slash Sanjay from
India
and he's happy to talk and help me out I
have no issues with my phone I just
uh
yeah I have no issues with my phone and
applying Sanjay end because my husband
is a you know [__] whatever right but
like
I think it can just be shortened into
something a little bit more
palatable this is just a lot of words to
get to the ending
and it could be maybe like I'm I get
along with customer service more than my
husband
oh yeah
yeah that could kind of be how you start
it off
so now like the premise is a little more
established as well
yeah
so now when I get in a argument with my
husband I call Sanjay because he's and
he's willing to fly to New York this
weekend so yeah
he listens he rate like there could be
more parallels of like the how they ask
you to like stay on the line for a
survey
yeah
um things like that you know yeah that's
nice
thanks Victoria
um
keto Carol
here we go
oh she said totally missed you guys
being gone two weeks oh thank you
lady Carol Jerry crawl said MC come to
Phoenix oh and hillmc
Phoenix the other week
say what well I said I was just in
Phoenix the other week I should have hit
him up oh
next time next step uh I learned a lot
from the guys I date recently I learned
the difference between probation and
parole I should set my sights higher
like Amy for a guy with a resume instead
of a record
oh that's funny
that's all there
that's not that like probation and
parole resume and record
at solid
of a record and I wonder it seems like
it's part of the problem is where you're
finding your guys so there could be
a fun like dating app word play or
something
yeah yeah like
something like I'll stop I should stop
uh
I should stop getting on police blotters
for
like almost like dating app that's a
police blotter like I'll stop looking on
police blotters for guys and I'll start
looking on LinkedIn or something that's
like a lineup
yeah I'll stop looking on a lineup and
instead look on LinkedIn something like
that yeah lineup in LinkedIn is very
funny
yeah I think there's a lot more
parallels between dating and like yeah
police
type deal you could pull from that's
very funny though nicely done
[Laughter]
girls in Phoenix too
HF yeah yeah yeah
Phoenix has a great scene Arizona is a
really good scene
oh my God I completely missed on just
letting people know
it's all right you'll be back a week
yeah I'll be back for sure
um HS a top selling car in America is
the Chevrolet citation named after
citation a ticket police give for a
minor offense can you imagine that here
in the UK driving a Land Rover cannabis
caution
I like the Cannabis joke and he's in a
suit like he looks like a lawyer
yeah he looks like he owns the company
yeah
uh I'd probably say the only thing would
be just less words like the Chevrolet
citation and then the Land Rover
cannabis cautioned I would just use just
like Mercedes caution or if you're gonna
go with the c uh
is it like or like uh
trying to think of a European car but
he's not doing a European car
you can just saw the key of caution or
like
Nissan caution you could do anything
uh
cannabis caution but it has a funnier
word than like Land Rover in the Land
Rover yeah yeah that makes sense
the Kia cannabis caught yeah I like I
like that with it's like the hard the
hard consonants
I don't think there's a yeah yeah I
shouldn't think if there's another K
name cars
um even a Corolla would be funny Corolla
cannabis caution oh yeah yeah yeah
uh Greg Brown I do see yours now it did
go through
um let's see
well yeah HF is there is there a British
car that has like a hard consonant that
would play with cannabis caution
um oh another cannabis joke
I told my boss I smoked weed since
she talked about doing it a while back
she told me I was lucky she didn't drug
test so I said don't you mean you were
lucky you didn't drug test
my boss is moving wings
is is your boss lucky because she would
have missed out
on working with you
this is confusing is that where
it was looked weird
she told me everything's great and
um
and um
a Zuma said smoke weed every day
hilarious
that's so
they said all right exactly I'm a great
employee oh nice
so I think just pref I think um
saying you're a good employee so it
could be like
uh after winning employee of the month I
told my boss I smoked weed and then that
can imply that like you're a good
employee and isn't she lucky and then
how you say it of like don't you mean
you're lucky you didn't drug test
you know you can deliver it with a lot
of emphasis there yeah that's funny
uh next
Gustavo
open mic night is great unless you're in
jail and your name is Mike then open mic
night hurts
that is
ridiculous
oh my gosh that is so ridiculous
[Laughter]
I didn't see that coming yeah
it's very ridiculous it's very simple
but it's pretty good I really don't hate
it there could be a tag around like a
type five
um
set list it's a bringer show I mean
there's probably other tags you could
have around it but oh my god let's hope
it's did you say let's hope it's not a
bringer oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's really funny
um the only thing about this joke I like
this as it is if you add too many comedy
things not everyone's gonna know but
this is funny because I think everyone
has heard of Open Mic nights that's
really funny
yeah
yeah that's solid
that's so solid very nice
nice job Gustavo yeah well done dude
beans rice
my sister got married to the first man
that admitted when he was wrong and he
judges everything by appearance she
asked how do I look he says you could
lose 20 pounds but I could be wrong
oh
just got married to the first man
my sister married the first man that man
he was wrong
yeah
I like this I just don't not sure
that there's a punch line
I feel like you're just stating a lot of
facts about this guy
because everything you're saying about
him is like in line with what he is
so there's not like a surprise
so what was he wrong about like
that he admitted he was wrong
about marrying her
um
I actually think admitted he was wrong
doesn't actually make sense for the joke
it's the
Mary the first guy who judges everything
by appearance
she asked how do I look he says you
could lose 40 pounds
yeah that's really it
nice
cool beans
thanks Bean dries
cool beans rice
but I do like the whole premise of
talking about like your sister and how
she married someone who's not great
seems like there's a lot of good
material there
oh you thought he wasn't great I thought
he was pretty honest
[Laughter]
well you've been married longer than I
have how long you been married
uh dude it'll be 16 years in February
all right all right wow
yeah man
that's great congrats
Championship stuff
Championship baby
John Mondragon they didn't offer late
checkouts as my hotel at my hotel so I
played Latin music in the room till 4 pm
and the housekeepers thought somebody
was already in there
well I used to refill mini bars
um not to brag
but um
I used to be a mini bar attendant I
would refill many bars
uh AKA eats snacks all day and um
so I I get the joke but I mean I could
see
it come like I could see this coming off
as racial like oh this guy
this guy said Latin
music he's saying all housekeepers are
Latino you know so
I I could see it being interpreted that
way of like why is this white guy saying
Latin
for sure
but um
so I get the joke but for the sake of
doing it yeah I could see this coming
off as just like
oh he that's racist you know what I mean
yeah I mean I think
yeah this is one of those things you
know I always say you gotta put yourself
out there to see how people react to it
but just know that it could come off
that way but you should definitely try
it on stage and you know
act it out to see how people respond to
it because if you look like you
shouldn't be saying it or if they don't
like you like that then
you you can't get away with it but if
they do like you and then like oh okay
we get it we use funny and he can make
this kind of joke then you might get
away with it
true true yeah
try it on stage yeah
really go for all of our feedback like
oh absolutely you're all right on stage
to you you mean like they have to like
you and be okay with the kind of jokes
that you're saying
uh
Greg Brown I think we're getting ready
to land This Plane here I think this
yeah let's land it my New Year's
resolution is to stop masturbating I
call it going hands-free in 2023
[Music]
stop masturbating I call it going
hands-free in 2023
I mean
it rhymes
yeah I think
um
almost feel like stop
masturbating
is the punch line so I almost feel like
my New Year's resolution is to go
hands-free in 2023
AKA
stop masturbating
you're so that seems to be the bigger
punch line you're such a professional
actually let's break down the structure
of this I think masturbating should go
on the other side yeah yeah just just a
quick uh reorganization there and I
think this joke has legs
[Laughter]
I mean I didn't say it was a good joke
but
I think flipping it will help
yeah
nice
just let's just swap it out just switch
it up oh my heavens
where are we at oh nice
let's not end it I'm not into a master
page
hahaha
um
that might be the way the cookie
crumbles though
I believe it is it was only right and he
tried to post it a bunch of times
apparently
[Laughter]
I wonder why it kept getting flagged
um hilarious
wow we rolled deep today we got up to
like 38 people at one time
legit dude yeah we do this every um
do this every uh every Tuesday
and then we do
the right 10 Club every Wednesday
morning
I don't know maybe not
this may be it I don't know
I had a happy ending I hate you Jerry
for that
[Laughter]
unbelievable
unbelievable oh my God
we'll be back next Tuesday
we're gonna do this once again yeah
tell your friends
every Tuesday at
5 p.m Eastern Time Alvaro said you think
you're gonna get a lot of New Year
resolution Comics probably
oh for sure oh my God December
um I was in uh Dallas and I went to this
open mic in Dallas and at least like two
or three people that were on the open
mic
just finished their fantasy football and
had to do an open mic so they brought a
lot different friends out
but it was a lit Open Mic because there
was a lot of people there so it ended up
being a good Open Mic because there was
like real audience members there and
then the guy who actually the two people
did
comedy one was really good the other was
trash
but overall it became a good Open Mic
because they brought all their people
that's not a terrible
idea for a show to like produce shows
for
Fantasy Football Fantasy Football people
because they bring people
you know that's not a terrible idea
ful idea at all
interesting
all right well let's land This Plane
what do you say
do it
well we appreciate y'all hanging out
yeah we will be back
we will be back uh I actually I don't
know if I'll be back in time but
hopefully I should be because my flight
is on that uh Tuesday back from the
national championship game
um
so
I just I forgot what time I'm getting
back so just a heads up
Okay cool so we may not be back
um if Yoshi's not here I'm
it's up in the air I will say
um I'm just gonna be honest 2023 I'm
just gonna be honest yeah we're gonna be
honest look Mom
I don't know I don't know
uh it's Akuma said heads for you 2023
[Laughter]
but yeah if y'all if if y'all want I
just posted a link to my newest YouTube
video so I can go check that out and at
least Aaron just share it just share it
please
I'm betting everything I got on this
channel and if it doesn't work I gotta
go back to refilling mini bars
um and my metabolism can't handle it so
but yeah
y'all have um
a great day we love you all is that all
right that's it
angels on y'all angels on y'all we'll
see you next Tuesday y'all
bye
[Music]